uh the three months ended and I ended up
working inside of an itoyokaro for a new
Supermarket Giant Supermarket which has
clothing stores it has um shoe stores
toy departments it's like a mall it's
like the Walmart basically yeah uh but
they're all unique stores though they're
all their own little stuff so this guy
who had helped me be a liaison with the
first company I came with he thought I
had some real potential
potential in what teaching like like I I
guess if I you know self-deprecating
aside I think I'm a pretty okay
communicator and I I can motivate very
much so yeah so you got potential kids
so he was like I want to start a new
company with just you as the main
teacher you're the only teacher and
we're gonna set up in this this
Supermarket Mall place okay and I was
like okay and uh I'm getting a massive
increase in my salary and I was like
that sounds great he found me an
apartment
um I had to give the car back so it had
to be within walking distance
and but Winter's approaching I did not
know that nigata leads the nation in
snowfall every year oh yeah it's insane
oh yeah before we get to this point what
what did you do about accommodation
prior to this did they give you a place
they did okay okay and and they they are
they almost every single Corporation
will give you a place to stay because
for more it sounds like it just sounds
like you hit the ground running you like
landed in the next few days you were
like you're living here now yeah yeah
yeah yeah it really was and yeah I mean
to reiterate again it's no cell phone
there's no I have no PC yeah I um I
don't speak the language certainly was
there ever a point where you're like I
think I made a mistake here almost every
day but uh but see for me no I didn't I
think I'd already kind of the die had
been cast in my opinion and I there are
there are very few honestly speaking I
wake up still to this day and it sounds
so cheesy but I always find something
new in Japan to enjoy or that or that I
like about Japan yeah and I knew when I
went back to America my first time
during this this career I thought I miss
home as in Japan and I was like yeah
that's that's where I live now so yeah
there was a lot of Trials I was I was
dead broke for about seven years of my
life like right could not you'd have to
choice of like the month of October like
go out and have fun with my friends once
or eat
um I'll go out with my friends and just
make it work so like geez it was the the
finances especially can be really tight
into Oklahoma and they don't pay a lot
so for sure yeah so yeah yeah so anyway
it starts snowing a lot I'm working in
this super mall this Supermarket Mall
place and I realized this guy has
actually no business sense at all and uh
we have no curriculum we have no
materials but uh I I show up every day
at the uh this this place and I'm the
only guy there and I didn't know this in
these malls all of the shop owners stand
outside when the when it right when it
opens and you all say like welcome in
Japanese yeah I think the the word for
that is
yeah it's kind of cool I was going out
there every morning and I was going
and I was negating that I was like
you're not welcome here because I didn't
hear it right and like inishai Mase yeah
yeah
I was like you're not welcome don't come
to my shop I don't care and then finally
this this guy who sold Italian clothes
next to me yeah I never saw a single
purchase there but
he was like he wrote a message and he
was like you are foolish you keep saying
you're not welcome I think he was saying
I made a mistake but yeah yeah I was
like
and so what ended up happening a long
story short
um this business crumbled almost
immediately okay did you get paid at all
I did but there was real oh I should
mention they did finally get me a work
visa on my second month working so I
worked illegally for about nine weeks
and then they finally got me the thing
so they should have that sounds like it
was they kind of dragged you here didn't
tell you anything it was a mess yeah
that sounds like they did it's almost
like they were like hoping you would
quit after the first couple no I mean
it's just something like they were
needlessly risking because it wouldn't
harm them if you yeah no certainly not
yeah and well I give them some benefit
of the doubt given that yes they were
unorganized certainly but
um there was the big earthquake and
maybe that that slowed down some of the
I don't know that's what I hope it
happens it could be so this guy went out
of business well so we ended up selling
this and sometimes Japanese businesses
get kind of creative with how they sell
programs and things and we had like a
point system where like you could buy by
33 million points in each lesson you
could choose to spend 12 000 of them for
50. and I was like this makes no sense
to me but he wanted people to buy
lessons in bulk so that we would pocket
a lot of initial money and then he lost
it all in Pachinko like every day so oh
yes he did if I needed to find him for
something I didn't have to go far to the
local Pachinko place and he he was like
we were how did he even get this money
to get off the ground I think they gave
him a fairly sizable loan to and uh you
know to do this all they wanted at the
Pachinko yeah he wanted at the Pachinko
come on but I could not imagine going
just to be like where's my boss oh he's
gambling all my wage away yeah well that
and we still didn't have the the right
formula for like what am I teaching
exactly like I don't know what's
happening but I made the best of it that
I could and his brother who spoke about
35 words of English helped write some of
the a b dialogues and those made
absolutely no sense
it's a conversation between two
characters and it and be like hello and
he'd be like die and I'd be like
I'd be like I was like I don't think
that's where we should start because
this was at a grocery store and he's
like what to do when you run into a
murderer
I know I know that there is uh malls and
there are different things but I've
never heard of lessons English lessons
given out on a mall no we were pretty
much the pioneers of this one
well to be fair at itoyokato sometimes
you can find a a kaiwa that's kind of
closed off a bit for children but we had
marketed ours for an adult so I was done
teaching kids I've played too much
dodgeball in soccer and it's been you
know I was like I want to try and
planning right I actually wanted to
teach English that's what I thought yeah
and then so his a b dialogues and he
always defended them by saying they're
almost I'd be like so the scene would be
like we're packing for a a trip to
America and I'd say like honey where's
my underwear and she'd be like you ate
it and I'd be like this doesn't make
sense like none of it this is not even
like a real conversation average
American conversation
and so I was like we need to rewrite
these to be like you know did you know
what's the flight number did you confirm
the passport stuff or let's go through
like useful and we had a lot of uh
discussions about this and while he was
just gambling Pachinko right and um
needless to say it kind of became this
finger he wasn't moving his feet to
renew my Visa and uh this now gets into
pretty scary territory where he's like
I'll recontract you for another year but
you know we're not making enough money
you're gonna have to take a huge cut in
salary I was like you've been we hired
like these other people to help like uh
because you know we I needed somebody in
the classroom who spoke Japanese too
yeah help if I was like this is what I
want to tell you yeah and he would miss
their payments for like four months and
they were Japanese really sweet Japanese
women and you're just thinking this is
not working so I I had very little money
left I packed up and I visited a friend
in Tokyo and I had two days to find a
job before I had to go back right and I
I went to various places and I found an
akaiwa which I'd not taught at before
other than my own failed business
venture where you know I was The Prodigy
of English teaching and we found this
one and I thought this is perfect
because the emphasis was English through
drama and I thought that's perfect I can
do that that was the biggest mistake of
my entirety that was the worst job I've
ever had and I and I gotta say if again
just rock up to this place you're like I
want a job well I was begging um but it
was it was something like that I I
remember you know I talked to the guy
and I said listen I I've got to get this
place I don't have a place to live I'm
out of money I'm out of time I can start
any just I have to get out of this and
he was like it's okay mate it's all
right calm down and I I remember he
looked at me right in the face and he
was like you're gonna be a good teacher
and it's going to be all right
welcome home and I said like oh thank
you so much Mister you're so kind and
now he's like time to die you know I was
like oh God it's overworked so anyway
that was the hardest one because you
teach I had this class called Joyland
and Joyland was four hours and it was
two-year-olds and one and a half year
olds and you eat lunch with them you you
sing songs you do things and it's the
hours are from like 11 A.M or 9 A.M to
8pm but there's breaks in like the
middle or you know this is the akaiwa
lifestyle so you have to be ready to be
paid very little and be always on call
and the materials are there for you but
it's it's a really stressful situation
and I I think that was the unhealthiest
I've ever been it was a really tough job
and after about a year of that I I
couldn't hack it I just couldn't do it
and I was like all right I got an
opportunity to teach at a high school
and that was when I started to really
change my Outlook of why I think
teaching is a good job in this country
if you take it seriously and you can
find ways to make it entertaining but
also start adding in a lot more
educational elements yeah then you can
start saying like yeah you know what I
can teach English I'm actually
knowledgeable I've studied this and then
by the end of my career I switched to a
private high school in Tokyo with a
guaranteed like pension with like um a
bonuses and like a imperf I could work
there forever and that's very very rare
in this country so I think to make a
this whole thing makes sense if you
really want to be in Japan it's not bad
to be an English teacher it's it's yeah
people are going to make fun of you yeah
you're gonna feel like this is not what
I thought it was okay wait do people
make fun of you yeah of course well okay
I I haven't heard of that though yeah I
haven't heard of that I guess I have the
only place I've ever heard of it or seen
it is when people try to I suppose you
know people who have moved here and have
managed to move here without going
through the common teaching route I
think there's some kind of like
superiority complex where it's like I
did it not in the way that everyone else
oh yeah I did it in my own way I use my
own skills to get here like I didn't
just apply to this English thing I'm not
like everyone else it's like that and
everything right yeah the norm they want
to feel like they're better so I think
yeah for sure yeah well I mean it has a
bad reputation because the salary is so
low what is that the average so on an
egg highway I mean okay wait let's see
this has been a while since 10 years ago
where I started my first month stuff was
about Juku months about 1900 a month but
I was in the countryside
well you know it changes depending on
the year so like let's just say 100 yen
is a dollar for the sake of arguments
about 1900 yeah it's about 1900 a month
and that was actually pretty good for
that area you know and I was doing all
right and I could live I'm sure the cost
of living was a lot lower so I think my
rent was 400 and I had I had like a
three LDK it was like a tatami room yeah
I had like
um a like a bathroom I live in poverty I
feel like now like
like this table is bigger than my
apartment now so like like it's you know
it was very spacious and it was really
nice but um then when you move to to the
akaiwa it was about 2300 a month which
in Tokyo Yokohama it gets pretty tough
yeah especially when you have like
Municipal tax in this country yeah the
rent was 900 a month for me yeah and I
was with a discount and um and you also
have to pay things like health insurance
and there's always a lot of stuff that
you know then I took a pay cut to teach
at high school and I worked at Interac
which is a very famous placement company
yeah for schools not a kiowa's and that
one paid about and then of course income
tax as well so you don't take home 23.
yeah that was about 2200 a month and it
was man there were times seriously where
you I had to eat just eggs and rice for
like six weeks during because and you
need to know this one thing if you do
work at those schools they will take out
out sixty percent in August because
there's no classes so you get prorated
pay see if you whatever it's 60 of 2200
was you're looking at like a paycheck
that's eight or seven hundred dollars
wait it's just August or no there's more
actually so that's the biggest one
though August August is the summer
holidays yeah they can do that they do
that yes and then you have in December
and January there's like 75 to 80 pay
then you have it again in uh March
because the end of school year this is
something that is the hardest part
because some months you'll feel good and
then the holidays come around everyone
wants to go out and have a beer or
celebrate but the August payment is two
months later so it's right on that
October first pay right you get 700 and
you're like you're like this isn't even
gonna pay the rent no it doesn't and
luckily you know if you're responsible
you'll have no problems
if you're responsible
um
it's pretty tough now to kind of give
the other side when I worked at the
private high school I made really really
decent money not even close to what I
would consider a teacher should make of
that effort of like how much you're
there but that one was closer to in a
yearly some 35 to 45 000 a year okay
which is that's a very respect and um I
had an opportunity to keep growing that
each year I stayed so that's pretty good
then yeah yeah that's I would say so
just being honest it's probably one or
two percent of people can get those
opportunities it's called a direct hire
so you cut out the middleman and you get
uh directly like from the school yeah
right